welcome to this video mm-hmm what is
this Nico line or it's in okay I have
played a chant oh I have a really bad
score one and a half out of six that's
not good he plays a bogo style opening
against me okay yeah I know something
about this let's see
yeah this is some almost a theoretical
position almost d5 your interesting way
to play this just plain normal moves not
doing anything fancy okay he wants to
play Bishop a6m that's quite apparent do
want to take should be three okay let's
keep it simple I was thinking Bishop e6
but he didn't didn't go for that okay
maybe I can take eat eggs and before for
slight advantage here now he has to play
c6 I guess if he allows me to play b5
he's okay GI that doesn't look good it's
not terrible for black but this is
better for I know this position so queen
bee three for Bishop before oh come on
it's not sure if it's the most precise
move but
ok I want to trade stuff anyway and now
play for rook a 1 or you'll see one
and that looks very very problematic for
like he moves the rook Wow
check wonder why this is even possible
this is one reason why I wondered this
canada i can just take it here right so
don't see any any sort of counter play
ok so I'm going to take it on past
summer I guess yeah so what is the the
most aggressive way to play tonight x I
guess and Bishop e2 just attacking the
h-bomb and I'm good I got Queen d6 still
in the in the mix
yeah my back rank em that's the only
issue so h 3 and 4 for King edge to
I think Hebrew do when he has a chick
okay so d5 winning a piece on is there a
big big trick that I'm missing I don't
think so sorry voice is feeding me a bit
black resides yeah he absolutely had to
place his six I think I mean the whole
position is it's slightly I mean white
is better anyway but but and hoeing b5
is really weird he has to place his six
I mean is this kind of thing it white is
better of course but if you if you allow
b5 your strategically speaking it's it's
very difficult c7 is always a weakness
d5 is a weakness if you want to see a
game with a similar structure this is
Calderon Ian from the latest state Tata
Steel childhood they had additional a
pawns but this was a similarly
problematic structure term care for rue
k 1 I just I can just trade stuff and
yeah okay this is completely ignoring
check this this IDM good it was very
difficult anyway g5 is giving it away
immediately adhere to do something like
this now Queen back and try to defend
this very passive position it's very
difficult for him to get rid of the
weaknesses I mean if it moves a see porn
there is still being deep on week so
plus the two bishops it's a very bad
position I mean the question is somehow
to how to play it exactly I'm something
like if we go screen age do I trade
probably i do the two bishops is very
nice and game
remove this night go for f3 what I'm
talking about is this kind of chess kind
of thing and then here's an interesting
moment what am i doing with with the
pieces um yeah I mean move like that
comes into consideration to play a three
maybe night here the other ideas just to
allow the trade which is not bad but you
don't want to trade trade that much so
probably would have played that for
three in something or not f4 force F 396
back yeah here can actually take problem
for for this the night night over here
to be three and so on this is just
eternally better for white okay well
thanks for watching